it leads us to this thing
which i think is the heart of what we're
what we're trying to talk about here
which is so we're going to be a family
with two fathers
and and no mothers and what does that
really look like you know it's very easy
to just say okay gay people should have
kids or gay people should get married
and gay people shouldn't just say a lot
of things it's easy to say an awful lot
as you said it's not that easy for a gay
couple to have kids right so very
complicated so putting aside the if
you're going to go the surrogacy route
putting aside all the finances and all
of that stuff that that eliminates an
awful lot of people from even being able
to do it fortunately we're we're
able to do it okay uh but now it gets us
to the to the real part here which is
that now we're gonna live in a household
with two fathers there's gonna be no
mother involved and what does that
really mean
maybe we can talk about exactly
how it came to be that you'll have a
baby in your household in six weeks talk
about what you had to do
to make that happen and
why you made why you made the decisions
that you made
and
what advantages and hazards come along
with that sure so first
technically because there are biological
differences between men and women i
don't want to get us canceled on youtube
but it actually is true jordan uh you
know we could not biologically have kids
so you know just ourselves uh so we just
we talked about
adoption for a little bit we did we both
felt that the genetic component of this
was important to us
so for a little while we debated
uh going with my sister's egg we thought
we'd have two kids that was the the
general thought process in the beginning
and we thought we could uh take some of
my sister's eggs and she's a mother now
she's actually pregnant with her third
but that we could get her eggs and then
we would take david's sperm and then we
would have two children from that
after a long time of talking about a
year debating that back and forth and
going through all that there were a lot
of ethical and moral issues and my
sister then would sort of would be the
biological mother of my children i mean
there were all sorts of things that we
were about to traverse right and that's
all uncharted territory right all sorts
of yeah you think you know how that
might go and you think you know how it
might go if you have good will but that
does not mean that you know how it will
go and i have to say even that
conversation having that conversation
with my sister who was interested in you
know when when we came to her she was
sort of flattered and honored that we
were even considering it but then you
know we said why don't you stay with
this for a little bit then suddenly she
had a lot of those questions and she was
concerned if you know she shows up to
the birthday party and then feels this
odd jealousy or what if she suddenly
wasn't happy with the way that we were
parenting or that's a big one or a
litany of other things so even going
through that and this this obviously is
not the way that we ultimately went
about it even that was sort of a
maturation process and like you know
what are we really trying to do here so
anyway ultimately we decided to find a
an egg donor i mean basically it sounds
sort of uh glib or something but it's
it's sort of like tinder i mean you can
there are these websites that exist
where the the egg donors are on the site
and you try we tried to find a girl i
didn't really care that much about the
pedigree in terms of did they go to an
ivy league school or anything like that
we wanted to find a girl who obviously
was physically healthy most importantly
um that you know that didn't have major
issues in terms of genetics and all that
sort of stuff that we thought that sort
of looked like the type of girl that we
might be with so i didn't want you know
a six foot five swedish woman let's say
um
and so we have one egg donor meaning
there were multiple eggs and we
fertilized one with david sperm and one
with my sperm and we'll have two kids
right now we have two surrogates that
are pregnant and even talking about this
it's like man i get this is this is all
kind of crazy stuff putting aside
putting aside gay or straight related to
all of this the whole surrogacy thing is
is
it's fascinating that there are first
off women who are willing to to donate
their eggs and you know i i hear a lot
of people we talked about this there's
this criticism of somehow that you're
you're buying the egg and you're renting
the woman yeah
yeah
and of course there is a financial
component to it there is i'm not denying
that there is i can tell you having gone
through this process and and we had a
previous surrogate who had two
miscarriages they were also you know we
were doing a lot of this during kovid
and during kobit there were all sorts
the miscarriage numbers were through the
roof there were all sorts of weird
things the quality of the eggs wasn't
great they don't know exactly they'll
have to study this for years in terms of
what actually happened
but i can tell you that the women who
offer to be the surrogates and who are
offering their uh eggs
they are not doing this for the money
there's all sorts of other ways that you
can make money that anyone can make
money they are doing it they are they
talk about that they have this ability
and this gift that they can do um a lot
of them there are some that won't do it
for same-sex couples uh because of their
own ethical or religious views um the
surrogates that we found they actually
one of them had a gay brother i mean
there were all sorts of things that they
feel that they can help other people
have a family and what a better gift
there is but but all of that aside all
the science and genetics and all that it
leads us to this thing
which i think is the heart of what we're
what we're trying to talk about here
which is so we're going to be a family
with two fathers
and and no mothers and what does that
really look like you know it's very easy
to just say okay gay people should have
kids or gay people should get married
and gay people shouldn't just say
it's easy to say an awful lot as you
said it's not that easy for a gay couple
to have kids right so very complicated
so putting aside the if you're going to
go the surrogacy route putting aside all
the finances and all of that stuff that
that eliminates an awful lot of people
from even being able to do it
fortunately we're
able to do it okay uh but now it gets us
to the
to the real part here which is that now
we're gonna live in a household with two
fathers there's gonna be no mother
involved and and what does that really
mean right well and i understand some of
the reservations well yeah well so we do
know
we do know that
children who are breastfed do better yup
i believe that one year of breastfeeding
is equivalent to i think breast fed kids
have a five point iq advantage and one
point iq is worth one year of education
i have two freezers in my garage two
industrial freezers full of breast milk
right right that's right
has done all the research on this right
so another complication but okay and so
and we don't have data we don't really
have data on
motherless children
raised by fathers from infancy right
because it's pretty rare i don't know if
there's literature pertaining to that at
all we do have a literature on
mother-headed families without fathers
and the data there are crystal clear
it's not good to be fatherless now that
doesn't mean that there aren't some
women who are struggling mightily as
single mothers who don't do an
outstanding job but what it absolutely
and 100 percent means that on average
that's sub-optimal and badly sub-optimal
and so
it seems to me that the minimal stable
requirement for
ensuring the psychological health and
financial viability of a child is
something like a nuclear family
structure minimally right so you need a
mother and a father or at least you need
two people one who plays a maternal role
and one who plays a paternal role or
that they split those
two seems to be better than one now how
much of that's linked to sex we also
don't know you know it it seems that
the
feminine role
is more
accepting slash nurturing you see that
with
the proclivity of women to be more
agreeable temperamentally that kicks in
at puberty and so i think that you have
to be accepting
and nurturing
especially in your attitude towards
infants before they're
mobile so say before six months before
nine months an infant does no wrong it's
100 acceptance
the problem with that is that
that's not true as the child develops
because it has to switch to more of an
encouraging role it's like out of your
dependency into the world and the
paternal spirit
encourages that development now mothers
can do that too but
but roughly speaking women tend to do
the nurturing thing more and men do the
encouraging thing more so now the
question is
how do you mediate how do you
manage to fulfill both those roles
in the absence of
a heterosexual arrangement right so now
naturally we understand that there are
men who are more nurturing and women who
aren't as nurturing and all of those
things now you you know david pretty
well and we've been out to dinner with
tammy many times and you know him he is
incredibly warm and nurturing and loving
and deeply cares about all those things
and i'm telling you he is reading about
skin to skin contact every day yeah and
all of the breast milk stuff and
everything and i know he will have a
huge percentage of the stuff that a
mother would bring but i also no it's
not all of it
is that you guys have to do that
consciously yes right
with the with research in hand and to
build up that proclivity that would be
there more automatically arguably with
the mother and all the psychological and
hormonal transformations she undergoes
and that transition into breast milk
production and all of that which is a
fundamental transformation in a woman's
biology and her psyche now
you and david have
ample resources at hand financially and
intellectually that enable you to
traverse this pathway
as well as anyone is likely to do it but
it is
very interesting and salutary to hear
you also talk about the complications so
if you'd like to see more honest and
insightful conversations with jordan
peterson himself check out our jordan
peterson playlist which includes every
interview i've ever done with him and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist both are right over here and to
get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell